[Music]
now
coming through yes
right good evening members welcome to
the development committee uh
24th of september 2020 we get straight
on with the
agenda we have apologies for
absence from councillor yanu at the
moment
um i can't see councillor weston
at present there are no substitute
members attending um non-members
attending have noted councillor gooding
which takes us on to item number four
straight away minutes of the meeting
held on the 27th
august 2020 be happy for me to sign
those
as a correct and accurate record of that
meeting a show of hands won't be
sufficient
yeah thank you right item five
is declarations of interest
councillor merrick thank you chairman
um i don't in fact have a declaration of
interest
but as to item six as i was not
able to be present at the august meeting
of this
busy i did i did not hear the
debate for item six
which may be relevant for this evening's
meeting uh i will therefore
not participate in the debate uh nor
vote on that item
okay thank you councillor wilson
thank you chairman um non-pecuniary
interest
in as much as i'm a patron of this
establishment
thank you very much councillor butcher
yes thank you chairman um as uh
with councillor merrick i also wasn't at
that meeting
and taking any part in the debate so i
also will refrain from voting and
debating
in that thank you i'm adam six thank you
count slaves
just on mute please
your unmute hasn't worked
work on the keyboard for some reason
rather um similar to uh councillor
merrick
um i was not at the meeting in august
but i have taken uh quite a lot of
interest in this and read
all of the material that has come out so
i will be voting on this one
thank you okay thank you very much
so we'll move straight on to item six
um two eight four ferry road home bridge
as has been mentioned um this is a
deferred
item from last month and katie rogers is
going to take us through this one
thank you i'll just share my screen with
you
oh sonia i need you to enable me to
share my screen please
oh thank you
members this site is located towards the
northern end of ferry road
adjacent to the river crouch with the
site edged red
on the screen
this is a photo of the existing building
on the site
the proposal seeks to extend the
existing public house with an extension
to the east
where my cursor is here which would
replace the outbuildings
currently in this position on site
alterations to the existing building are
also proposed
which include demolition of this flat
roofed front extension here
the application was heard at the
development committee in august and
deferred to allow the applicant the
opportunity
to address issues raised by members
relating to car parking
scale and the external facing material
proposed for use
so on screen now you can see the
proposed site plan
in relation to parking members were
clear that the preferred base size of
5.5 meters by 2.9 meters should be
achieved for all new car parking spaces
at the site
this revised site plan shown on screen
shows that all new additional spaces
would now meet the preferred base size
this has resulted in seven fewer spaces
and the reorientation of some spaces in
this location where my cursor is here
the number of spaces to surf the
extended pub would remain acceptable
the applicant has previously had
previously proposed that the extension
and would be finished in siberian larch
the applicant has listened to members
concern in relation to this and now
proposes the use of ash sourced in the
uk
the scale and form of the extension
remain as originally proposed although
the applicant has sought to provide
further justification
as to the design approach so the eastern
extension would consist of these three
ridges
three sorry four ridges three of the
ridge lines would be significantly lower
than the roof height of the existing
building
whilst one would be higher this one here
but it would only be marginally so and
no higher than the chimney
ridges of all the same height would
appear rather uniform whilst the
proposal gives variation and visual
interest
there would also be significant
separation between the bridge
the highest ridge and the existing
building to allow visual distinction
the degree of separation would mean that
the extension would be less prominent
when viewed from ferry road
than the two-dimensional image might
suggest
the roof pitch also reflects that of the
existing building
so the applicant has provided this
illustration
the image on the left shows an angle on
the existing roof between
55 and 60 degrees with the extension
on the right hand side shown would
reflect this
one of the ridges being 55 degrees here
and another being 60.
this steeply pitched roof is
characteristic of traditional building
form and typical of design promoted by
policy dm1
which refers to the essex design guide
in addition the applicant has provided
this 3d visual image
which shows the degree of separation
between the existing building
and the the highest ridge
finally this image
although orientated differently shows
has been provided by the applicant and
shows historic barns
um with steeply pitched roofs adjacent
to the river
and the design proposed is reminiscent
of these
i'll take you back to the site plan
in conclusion the applicant has
addressed members concerns relating to
car parking and external facing
materials and provided further
justification as to the appropriateness
of the proposed design
the recommendation is therefore one of
approval and it should be noted that
there's a slight correction to condition
two
just to list two additional plans um
which will be required
in respect of an approval thank you
thank you uh we have a speaker statement
on this and i believe sonya is going to
read that one out for us please uh
statement is from uh mr michael hendry
of navigate planning
on behalf of the applicant i'd like to
take this opportunity
to thank the officer for a well reasoned
report
and welcomed the recommendation of
approval
further to the comments discussed at the
committee meeting on the 27th of august
2020
the applicant has considered the key
elements raised by members
namely parking materials
design and ridge height i address
moment in turn below
sorry um parking
the parking layout has been amended
requested by members
and as highlighted in the offices report
all parking spaces on the existing hard
standing
measure five meters by 2.6 meters which
is
in excess of the council's minimum
parking standards
all of the parking spaces on the
extended car park
meet the council's desired maximum
parking standards
and measure 5.5 times 2.9 meters
materials as requested the design
team has looked again at the choice of
timber cladding
and proposes a uk sourced thermally
treated ash
to increase its durability and would
accept a suitably worded condition
in respect of external materials
it should be noted that the change from
siberian larch
to thermally treated ash has doubled the
cost of the cladding
design and ridge height the design team
has looked again at the design and the
ridge height of the highest element
and has decided not to change the design
for the following reasons
the ridge is set well back in from the
original building
and will be less prominent from ferry
road than the two-dimensional
elevations would suggest the ridge is no
higher than the highest point of the
previously
approved motel scheme the ridge is no
higher
than the chimney of the existing
buildings the design
seeks to contrast with the original
1930s public house
and draw influence from traditional boat
houses
and warehouses along the river however
it is the modern interpretation of the
form and need not
replicate every element of a traditional
timber plaid
essex building the proposal
is designed to be visually stimulating
while respecting its setting to
emphasize the anchor
and hull bridge as a destination on the
coastal path
the relatively steep roofs were an
intentional reflection of the local
vernacular
and relate directly with the angles
contained in the roof of the existing
building
a reduction in the angle of the pitch to
reduce the ridge height
would appear visually jarring and squat
in the overall composition and would
would be detrimental to the visual
appearance of the proposal
the design has the support of the
conservation officer
and the planning officer the design has
the support of the economic development
officer
due to its job creation and visitor
attracting potential
and concludes that the proposal is bold
and
eye-catching and could serve to further
highlight hullbridge
as an important visitor destination on
the coastal path
it should be noted that the proposal
will result in a 2.5 million investment
in the anchor
the retention of the existing 30 jobs
the creation of 20 new jobs
and the continued support of up to 60
jobs in the supply chain
the proposal represents a significant
boost to hulbridge
local businesses and the wider
population
all of the above is set against the
backdrop of the most
challenging trading conditions ever
faced by the industry
and one in which many hospitality
businesses will not survive
officers have again considered the
issues carefully
and have concluded that the proposal
represents a positive contribution to
the area
both visually and economically i
reiterate my support for the office's
recommendation
and trust that the information provided
will assist members in the debate
thank you thank you
members obviously you're aware that we
had a full and comprehensive debate on
this at the
last meeting so i do intend to guide you
to discussing the
items that we specifically deferred to
this item for
that being the car parking the cladding
and the clarification about the relative
scale of the
item so um councillor stanley you've
indicated if you'd like to go first
please
thank you chairman um could i just look
at the
uh the drawing that uh shows the
roof line and the
next one i believe shows all four uh
roof lines there seems to be a little
bit of differential in there in the in
as much as
the roof is split into two in other
words it's like a dutch
roof the way it's weights is is that
going to be built like
that's that's the one yeah um you've got
a
what it's
graduated into two pieces in the roof
line
whereas it doesn't show that on the main
drawing so
which one is right is it going to be a
complete
roof on that angle all the way down or
is it going to be a split roof
the the the item that is on your left
hand side
is the existing and the one on the right
hand side
is the proposal okay right
um right so and the other question is
what difference would it make if that
the the larger building the apex or the
top of the
the larger building what difference
would it make to the architectural
and uh deliverance of this
surrounding scenery if that was brought
down to the same height
as the original building um
on on that one councillor stanley that's
not the proposal
that is front of us to determine that's
a
a subjective question so i'll have to
sort of steer on that on that one that
we can't
take that into account we must take only
into account the proposal that's in
front of us
please okay
uh so that that was my
that was my comments i'm more than
happy to to uh understand that the
proposal of uh not using a siberian
larch to
uh using ash which is uh accommodated in
this country and it gives people
uh those that are supplying and and
manufacturing the the product for this
development um the developers have
recognized that and i wholeheartedly
agree with them
it keeps employment into the into this
area thank you very
thank you very much then councillor eves
you're next
nikki chair um i have to say i
am um very encouraged by the economic
contribution
that the development of this size and
scale and amount of money will be making
to the area and i have to
applaud them under under current
situations for taking
on such a huge project when the future
is so uncertain
having said that as i said at the outset
of the meeting i was not at the meeting
in august but i have followed the
developments and listen to the
debate that was had in detail
there are a number of issues that i have
with
the the proposal and that we are
discussing tonight
if i take the pitch of the roof for a
start off
um the there are a number of issues with
the way that the applicant has actually
put this forward
as you will see on the items that are on
screen and the drawings that are on
screen at the moment the original
building is a man's side roof
now for those of you who don't know what
a man's side roof is a dual pitch roof
to say that the actual proposal is
replicating that is quite
un untrue it does not in any way shape
or form
you've got an average angle there that
you're picking up on
yeah okay fair enough i get that but to
say that he's replicating
anything from the original building is
not true
the photographs that we were told that
we were showed in the presentation
they show rooms which are i would
guess by what i saw there 45 degree
pitch which would be expected to be
somewhere around about that
in the traditional building these are
nowhere near that pitch
so uh there is a design issue that i
think they're
on the pitch is an issue the other issue
is the materials
um i appreciate that the applicant has
changed the siberian lurch for english
ash
but the fact of using timber on the
outside
in the aspect that they're using it
there i would bring to mind
a building that is in shubery that is in
townfield road
that's a block of flats that was
actually clad
in a similar way and when it first
was commissioned it looked spectacular
and i
i don't hide that fact and i i would
reflect the same
uh sort of feeling when this is actually
finished
if it goes through but the fact is if
you go down there now
what happens with timber in this kind of
aspect is it goes
very dark grey in a very short space of
time
and this building i i i'm sorry to say
but i think it will look like a glorious
carbuncle
within a very few years and the choice
of the
outside materials here considering that
you're also
in a seafront effective
atmosphere there will not look good
within a very short space of time so to
say that this
actually proposal is meeting cp1 and dp1
in our uh
our standards i think is actually not
right and
i i cannot support this application with
the uh
the actual um material that the
applicant has put forward
the roof height they did actually say
before
was um no higher than the original but
now they've actually changed that to be
the
height there's no less height than the
chimneys
um there's just one small point which
is a practical point that i'd like to
question i don't see any
provision on site for uh commercial bin
storage
that that that that issue was covered it
is there okay
that that as soon as it has been covered
yeah that's it thank you okay thank you
very much
uh councillor wilson
thank you chairman um i think that
the um the developer has actually
listened to what the
um committee spoke about last time
i think they ticked the boxes with the
improved parking
um so that's not a problem um we did
specifically ask for a different
material
and again they've listened and
notwithstanding what kansas region said
um they've actually gone with that i
think the thing that was outstanding
really was the scale
and i i understand what the developers
are saying
it's it the height of it and the mass of
it
is different from the motel that was
actually granted planning permission
so some of the the um the talk that we
had
at the discussion that we had at the
last meeting was around the size and the
scale
um but some of that wasn't really
material issues it was more to do with
the fact that this is different um and
again notwithstanding the point about
the the roofs this is an interpretation
it's not an exact copy of the existing
building
um so i would fully support this and i
would move um
for approval okay thank you very much
council mr shaw thank you chairman
um i'm going back on the notes that we
had on the last development and i
actually would congratulate the
developer on listening to everything we
actually said
um and i think they've actually
addressed
everything that we asked for so thank
you very much
thank you cancer fd i don't really want
to repeat what the last
two have said too much but i
wholeheartedly agree with that
uh this is subjective some people like
it some people don't
particularly don't like it it wouldn't
stop me agreeing it
um they've listened to what we've said
and they seem to fulfilled it
and i think this will look great in
holbridge so inc
which was which will be a mixture of
modern and historic
thank you thank you councillor hawkway
uh yes thank you chairman um yes i
i would like to uh congratulate the
uh um agent and developer for um
listening to uh what members uh said
in at last meeting and taking notes of
that and
providing us with an amended application
um i have read
um what was stated about the um
the issue to do with the uh the height
of the eaves and that um
i think overall on balance uh that this
is a better proposal um and at the end
of the day the
the extension proposed is a contemporary
design
um and um it's one of these sort of
things that um you know different people
will have different views on it but it's
not
not a an issue for refusing
uh this particular application thank you
chairman
okay thank you members no other members
are indi vindicated
uh councillor wilson has moved this i'm
happy to
second it from the chair we have
recommendations
on page 6.1 of the report through to
page 6.6 with the small
addition of a couple of extra plans as
mentioned by the officer
so i'll now move through to the voting
as usual if you could please indicate if
you want
a recorded vote then the way you want to
uh vote so it would be uh four for the
approval
or against so counselor butcher please
yes thank you chairman um i should
abstain as i said at the beginning
thank you councillor fd
for um for the uh application
and um i've got my plane's gone and uh
can't stay
recorded thank you councillor eves
uh no recorded and abstain thank you
abstain okay councillor hawkway
um no recorded vote and for the
application thank you
councillor merrick
overrecorded epstein thank you
councillor mrs shaw never recorded vote
on
four uh councillor mr shaw
no recorded vote and four thank you
myself no recorded vote and
four councillor stanley
no recorded vote and four thank you
uh councillor williams thank you
chairman
no recording vote and for
councillor wilson no recorded vote and
n4
thank you
that item is approved thank you
we move on now to an item that wouldn't
normally come before
us but this is a an officer's uh
application
88 parklands rochford and katie's going
to present on this one again for us
thank you this application relates to a
residential property in number 88
parklands and is before members as the
applicant is an employer of
oxford council this is an application
for a non-material amendment
this type of application allows the
applicant to seek to agree
minor changes to an approved scheme
without the need to reapply for
full planning permission in this type of
application the decision must be based
solely on whether the proposed change is
so minor
it could be regarded as having no
material effect compared to the approved
scheme
no public consultation is ever carried
out in relation to these types of
applications
in this case the original planning
permission approved was for a single
story side extension
the change the applicant proposes is a
reduction in the width of the side
extension by approximately 1.2 meters to
the front elevation
so that's that's this width here where
my cursor is
this change is necessary to avoid a
drain that cannot be built over
the height and design of the pros
extension would remain as approved
the change is considered so minor as to
qualify as a non-material amendment
and the recommendation is therefore one
of approval
thank you does anyone actually want to
comment on this one
no okay we won't go straight to the vote
then
the recommendation um is
on 7-1 and at the top of
7-2 so we'll go straight through again
um cancel butcher
councillor hawkway no recorded vote and
four thank you councillor merrick
a recorded vote and four councillor mr
mrs shaw
no record your vote in four thank you
cancer mr shaw
no recording bottom four myself no
recorded vote and four
council stanley no we called you both m4
okay councillor wilson
no recorded vote and four councillor
williams
and no recorded vote and for thank you
chairman thank you
that is unanimously approved then
so uh thank you very much for your
attendance members
and uh nice to have a swift meeting
tonight so i'll declare the meeting
closed
thank you good night all right
good night thank you good night good
night thank you